reject nation i'm greg i am aaron we're
gonna watch
2x6 umbrella academy
putting this up every other day
hopefully so subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever the next umbrella academy
reaction is up and here we go with info
dump youtube only allows for 10 minutes
worth of the show to be shown this is
going to be reaction highlights full
length reaction watch along
over at our patreon page speaking of
which we'd love it if you could go ahead
and show your support by becoming a
patronage today
we do a weekly q a podcast and we cover
many shows that have reaction highlights
and watch-alongs included for those same
exact shows all at the same tier and
those shows
are here we go supernatural dr ho jojo's
bizarre adventure the promised neverland
attack on titan death note my hero
academia could
gas hunter hunter one punch man full of
full metal alchemist brotherhood
violet evergarden demon slayer there are
many shows where we do only watch alongs
for them like
these shows that i'm showing pictures of
thanks so much for being here let's
watch this
[Music]
wow i like how they're showing us each
what's happening their
their time must be talking to raymond
oh you've seen the full context
damn straight hey get back here you
don't hit
my brother oh she still can't talk
either yeah she couldn't talk for the
first year she was there
wow he looks totally different
i have to go although they capture those
scenes kind of like from raymond's
perspective
yeah actually comes across just like a
shy shy timid
oh right now that's how they do it in
the 60s no man you got to get their
number wait a couple
days act like you're kind of interested
[Laughter]
frame is not about that [ __ ] we
gotta get one of those what are those
called uh the ornaments
we gotta get an ornament um
group
what a deal but the apocalypse there's
nothing
[ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] don't
listen to r5 diego this is a setup
we should go anyway says the guy who's
already stopped what is this
my god
we get no points
what a giveaway these are real people
they're not just
goddamn uh it looks so relaxing i'm
gonna stretch after this
okay cool nice there's an interesting
direction to take in my name
oh no
oh no this ain't gonna work how you how
you playing brother
yep called that [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah
i have a frog
[Laughter]
well played sir wonder woman doesn't
exist in this universe
now can he see that i guess not or maybe
[Laughter]
read a whole bunch of rumors i hear none
of you are racist anymore
change the world allison tell the
mannequin a rumor this is fun you could
actually see her have fun with the power
just get into a mic
oh this is great i love it they're
pushing her to this point fight the
power
just rubbering it up
damn those eyes though
[ __ ] [ __ ] so how long does the rumor
effect have is like is there like a
window on the rumor
wow oh man this is like total wish
fulfillment cathartic experience
oh burn that in uh she gets evil
do it more oh god isn't it
jesus she abuses it that's why she don't
use it yeah
it's a hello he's racist man i'm worried
about
her well-being but right screw that guy
that guy can go to hell
i heard a rumor that i won bingo i could
watch
a whole episode of just her just
rumoring okay
surprised i didn't try to do a saucy 60s
remix of rumor has it by though
now is five gonna tell diego about his
girlfriend
oh good question
looking out for her especially because
she knows too much about her
what's wrong
he's grown yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love the self-awareness of this scene
i call them
mean i can't chipettes a piss without
you nitpicking at my age
it's interesting that five was the
alcohol like in last season and now it's
a klaus
classical alcoholic but you did all the
other stuff too yeah
[Music]
that'd be crazy
what is your problem woman
that makes sense to ask i know your
favorite food is a plain hamburger with
two pickles
[Laughter]
oh klaus i hope you can win his heart
back
you know the truth about time travel
will be more believable
[Music]
oh no
don't mess with the timeline no i know
oh god this is
like he loves him so much
oh no he thought he could save his life
and then for him to show up like that
that's just heartbreaking because he
thinks he has a shot still
yeah oh jesus
[Music]
[Music]
oh she's the one who sent it she's
willing off diego huh because she thinks
it's going to refocus her daughter
it's going to backfire me lady
that's a really great shot i love
symmetry it makes me so happy
oh hey
the sibling hell yeah hell yeah
everybody
hey everyone except for luther too hey
that's great that makes me happy
umbrella academy
more like united academy
under an umbrella
ah hero shot yeah don't cry luther
who's sting
[Laughter]
that's great
no more numbers
no duping they're actually doing it okay
wow this is so great
[Music]
that's one
you would be surprised
hell yeah this is best in the season
wow that was cool
it felt like nonchalant
awesome
this is a fantastic delusion
poor diego
get him oh get him hard grace
this time
that actually broke my heart with each
other
[ __ ] man
[Laughter]
what
yeah taking the toll out of both of them
i'm ben
that was great that was an amazing scene
i'm still hurting for diego man yeah
no guys you gotta stick together team
zero doesn't work with that only yeah
don't let daddy tell you apart
oh yeah get klaus
[Laughter]
you're gonna pick him up i just want to
show you something oh ruin him
oh what
ah makes sense your boyfriend isn't the
nice guy you think he is
don't [ __ ] up time no mistake don't take
my wife
a crazy [ __ ] and i will turn you into
an android
[Laughter]
get your mama killed all right yeah the
one who's most like him oh he's
united with his know it's akin dad
descending blindly into the depths of
freezing waters and reappearing as an
anchor
that's what he said is this proportional
to the size of your ability
hmm start small
[Music]
[Music]
this is the best episode
who's here to kill no elliot's gonna
be the swedes oh no i loved all the
original stuff
that was great that was fantastic
that's a punch you're not gonna reach it
bro
you dead meat oh they speak
well the other guys oh jesus
oh he just held him in my hair oh that's
strong poor elliot uh oh
he didn't do nothing oh no
[Laughter]
this nasty it's called an affair
oh don't give up
ellen payne's jawline man trust her
oh trust me oh what a real reaction oh
that was great
that's such great acting so sweet
oh i felt very natural oh this would
make me sad now
oh god something terrible is going to
happen terrible
that's going to wake her up oh no oh
no bonnie's not allowed to be happy why
are you doing this to me
that's the hardest kiss i've ever seen
is that carl is that carl
he's just following carl no i knew i
didn't like you
damn carl oh
no who's watching your son
[Laughter]
oh no elliot oh no
oh no they killed him
i don't want to see his face i don't
want to see his face what they do to him
what do they do to him
oh [ __ ]
oh no he mutilated him oh god
they mutilated the guy for
oga eye for an eye we got it
we gotta find this song and then play it
enjoy it why would you
trust her take out who oh the board the
board the board
i said the boy i was like what the boy
oh
1982. oh she's gonna give him a
briefcase
oh [ __ ] dude
that was a fantastic episode
that was great that was fun they get
better by each episode that was
fantastic
that was yeah it made me it made
me appreciate the show especially
nationally yeah i didn't appreciate it
until this very moment and i wasn't
digging it before this episode
dude that was great that was so good
that was great i am legit in love with
this episode
i'd marry this episode put a ring on it
put a ring on this episode
um man a lot of stuff happened in this
one it's a thick episode it's a thicky
yet doesn't feel rushed or overly done
or overly compact with storylines well
it
it has a lot of information but it runs
so smoothly it's a believable course of
action for this
yeah 40 years god so good
they just they just know how to write
people
what would human beings be like in this
situation would people like this
ridiculous scenario you know but it's so
was so well told even like from the very
beginning
right with allison allison coming back
seeing the origin of
her 60s storyline with meeting raymond
and then them
experimenting with the rumor and having
fun with it i was like it's nice to see
alison have some fun with it but also be
aware of the dangers of the powers and
i love the trajectory of that like i
don't trust you too oh my god this is
great too
how can i ever trust you now though can
he ever really believe her
i would i would probably have the same
question the same thoughts being in his
situation like you can use this at any
time
and you can't use it on me yeah i mean
you've kept the secret for you
for a year a couple years yeah like i
don't know if i could try like
that level of realism with it yeah
that's how it makes sense that you react
this way yeah everything with those two
characters is like super believable
i get why she would fall for him i get
why they would really work with one
another but i also get like the doubt
that he would have
in his life after all this time
experiencing this new aspect of her
and the cathartic nature too of her you
know taking advantage of her powers to
mess with these racist white people man
was awesome
and it really goes to show something you
don't really see in the first season is
why she stops using her powers because
something bad always happens
yeah and you can really see like the
power trip wills turning in her eyes
gets addicted to it i get carried away
with it
[Laughter]
i know i would yeah man it's a dangerous
power to have i've watched shows like
jessica jones and i'm like man
kilgrave's powers would be sweet
this is why you can't mind control
people
who wouldn't want that come on i'm
surprised i didn't do like a like a 60s
remix of rumor has it or something yeah
i thought they wrote that scene so well
with klaus
trying to let go of his cult by telling
them the truth yeah
man and it was like of course they're
gonna try to follow him after that
because like
once you're so convicted into something
like anything to try to get you out of
it you're not having it and this is also
a time of
like believers i feel like we've you
know this is not a thing of disrespect
to people who have faith or anything
like that
and something religious it's just that i
think people being outspoken
about saying things if they believe
there is no god or whatever being
outspoken like that is
normal now and fine right back then it's
very taboo
yeah you could it's so like the
conviction of beliefs especially and he
does have just have a cult following
what i loved about the the storytelling
in that scene is that you could have
easily ridden that where it could have
been way too goofy
and way too cartoony and like such a
comedy scene
they did it in a way where i'm yeah this
is this seems plausible
yeah the beautiful thing about this show
and especially this episode is
everything that they
they do within the information they they
give to you it can be so wacky or done
in such a wrong way but it feels very
organic in the way that the show kind of
presents it to you every single moment
man like even with david showing up that
breaks my heart
you know it's a different type of
feeling as opposed to what
vanya's having with [ __ ] because you
know how much klaus
loves david and how he watched him die
and he grieved over that and this is his
one dying there's one chance he could
save his last opportunity
and he keeps going about it all wrong
and push and because of him
interfering pushed him to getting
enlisted sooner and then the
conflict that's a different actor than
the one who played david in the first
season right
totally yeah you know how much klaus
loves the guy
and uh you can really see like even the
few scenes they've had together the
affection that
you can see in klaus's eyes that this is
someone who clearly has a pass with this
person
this person doesn't know what i thought
this episode demonstrated really well
from cutting around to klaus
to vanya oh and then also with uh
also with allison they've done such a
great job at
what if people who grew up in a time of
like 2019
were transported to the 1960s where the
belief systems on things were
way different you know and really
dealing with
like them having to live here i think
it's fantastic stuff everything with
reginald
hey these are my favorite reginald
scenes thousand percent and b this is
just some of the best scenes
out of umbrella academy like when
they're all going to the elevator it's
it's just funny how
in the last episode we were talking
about how they want to be together
and they really feel like a family but
damn like the detail
of the psychology of these characters of
when they go to meet with their dad
the worst is going to come out of them
yeah even just
leading up to them meeting their dad
they start acting
bitter towards each other and snarky and
antagonizing one another
you know the children in them really
comes out whenever it's like oh
we like dad's on the horizon right now i
gotta reverse them back like how they
showed the first season
the very end where they're all holding
hands and shows them back as kids when
their dad is in the picture
it brings them back to that that stage
yes and that's no more evident
than diego and hargreaves conversation
yeah and we got to see the scene where
all the adults of them are interacting
with reginald
yeah which we've never seen before i've
never seen it's so
great the the richness of the writing of
how
reginald is not this is all new
information to him
right yet it's so consistent with a
version that you can imagine was like a
20 years ago
or whatever years ago version of this
guy where like the dad in him
still comes out because he was never
really a compassionate father
to me he was never like these are my
children you know
remember one two three four five so it
would just make sense that he would
treat them
exactly the same way he's treating them
right now and like that scene with diego
when he is like belittling him
and then then the stutter comes back
wow great job as an actor he just he
murdered that oh
he yeah he killed that scene dude he
killed that just him reacting to that
and you see
the breakdown in his face reverting back
to a child from
from standing to sitting with the tear
streaming down i went from like
like cracking jokes to that scene like
oh i feel bad about everything i just
did
i'm legit like i'm feel for diego right
now this sucks
you know he's getting bullied for
thinking and feeling a certain way when
he's like he's programmed that way by
that man yeah
you are the way you are the reason he is
the way is it's so
nuanced that whole like awkward family
confrontation scene it was either the
beginning of this episode or la
it was last episode i think i don't
remember at one point
i was like five is the one who speaks
the most like reginald yeah
and then to have that detail wrap back
around where they're having
a genuinely good bonding moment these
how these two characters are interacting
he hasn't seen his dad in forever
the beautiful thing about that
conversation to me is the fact that the
whole reason number five went to the
future in the first place was
to get away from his dad because he was
so stubborn and he thought he knew more
than his dad and his dad
is basically a know-it-all at this point
like he's smart he always
he always acts like he's the smartest
guy in the room for a technically
adult version of number five to
reconnect with his father after
45 years and having that conversation of
hey i screwed up and i should have been
more understanding them talking to each
other both as adults was really it was
really powerful
beautiful stuff yeah it was great
that's great i'm like mesmerizing this
episode because none of
the craziest moments are like action
scenes or something it's just like
great character scenes you know even to
that scene
towards the end with vania and [ __ ]
yeah that was very emotional and i'm
like sissy's performance there
uh whoever plays her it's top notch i i
do have a
slight i'm waiting to see the season
because i've said this with a lot of
characters already i'm waiting to see
how the season ends
i have a slight criticism i haven't
talked to you about this a slight
criticism about vanya okay other than
some scenes with [ __ ] she seems a
little
too chill
yeah she's super chill with everything
yeah she's being told and like too
nonchalant about so even write down what
the powers like
i feel like i don't know i don't quite
get the the choice
because she's high in between every time
they show her that's why she's so chill
really yeah are you joking i'm totally
jealous
it's like is there some detail you're
not totally missing out i don't know
she's baked the entire diary that's why
she could accept this so every scene
that she has with [ __ ] is
great and i feel like that's where
especially ellen page the actress really
shines there's
all these other choices in between where
i'm kind of lost on the wait why are you
why are you so like nonchalant why are
you like so laid back
is the word actually yeah yeah there's
multiple directions you can take the
amnesia aspect we're just like we're
just gonna like even though
she basically thinks she's from the 60s
at the beginning of when the show starts
she just takes it all like
like it's nothing sure like i'm not from
here
sure had powers yeah yeah it's cool like
it's a real go with the flow attitude
yeah
go with the flovania that's basically
her character i mean maybe she belongs
in the 60s then
i'm waiting to see until the whole
season's done because it's not like when
she's playing that
it's bad acting it's more of i don't
quite get the choice of the acting
or the or the writing that's basically
they don't want to make things
more complicated than they already have
going on the show so like we just want
them to be a family the only way to for
them to be a family is for them
for her to have a media so there's no
conflict with their past
like most of the complexity of her
character
all comes out with everything with [ __ ]
yeah and carl and at home there
yet it doesn't really seem present with
the umbrella academy stuff
and that's where my mind kind of goes
wait a minute
why are you so cool at like almost
everything that's just more of a choice
i don't quite get right now something i
don't understand it's not
criticism of the episode it's just like
the ordering she has top billing and i
feel like i don't feel like she's like
the top i feel like i've made sense in
season one
right and she's the biggest star of the
show and then you find out that oh this
really is all about her the apocalypse
and what's the cause the apocalypse the
way they
where she was treated so that makes
sense and i did have that thought here
too
of like it doesn't really seem like this
is element yeah it doesn't because
especially when at the umbrella academy
stuff i'm just like you don't really
you're the least interesting thing about
it right
when you should have like one of the
most compelling things yeah she's
literally like
the thing that caused the apocalypse
last time she's she's probably the thing
that can single-handedly
save them yeah she's basically like the
superman of this group like i said i'm
wait because i had that opening scene
with her where she's like badass
superhero
so i'm waiting to see how the season
unfolds before i can give a final stamp
on that because right now i have some
questions about the performance
basically another question i have is the
fact that
five came into what would have been the
apocalypse in the 60s with them all
together
so i'm like what would have brought them
together in any other circumstance to be
superheroes outside of five being there
i don't know
we'll let the way yeah we have some
questions
but still this is still my favorite
episode of of the season so far i don't
know if
i can say my favorite of the series for
sure however i'll say that
it definitely has some of my favorite
scenes from the series
1000 that whole dinner everyone had a
great mo
whether it was a couple of lines or just
a little brief moment like luther with
this with the shirt or
it was so or allison rumoring um
diego and facebook you got this whole
thing with ben possessing and i love the
way that was handled i'm just
because when ben does it it's so by
accident then ben goes and they're like
when they're at the table reginald
because you gotta imagine it from
everyone else's perspective who can't
see ben
i feel like you think it's gonna be
something epic and it's just ben falls
over and
everyone it's like he's like all right
classes whatever that was wonderful
nobody takes them seriously
sounds so bad uh but yeah the scene
worker reginald here was great
diego interacting with grace let's see
what happens with that i don't want to
get too caught up in theory discussion
and we'll just see yeah you got some
great cliffhangers so far to look
forward to with the whole
carl you know spying on his cheating
life
and uh where's who's watching their kid
i feel like there's a big thing
oh yeah elliott dying yeah i mean we all
knew he was gonna die we've been saying
that for like since the beginning
he's the kind of character who dies in a
show like this that's the most
tropey part of this episode is
especially with the plot unfolding
yeah they're going to kill him and leave
the message there and man that could do
a number on d.a i hope it does a number
on diego
feel bad about it because he's probably
going to feel it it's not really his
fault but he's gonna feel like it's his
fault and i like when they do that with
diego
that's the hero complex right there i
feel bad for uh so bad for elliott man
all he cared about was finding the truth
and the truth falls on his lap and gets
him killed
yeah with through no no no doing of his
own he's just been
he's been going along for the ride you
know the truth will set you to death
that's terrible and lila has feelings i
love his feelings who would have seen
that coming
caught him but i got to give some show
credit the way the handler
was acknowledging that with lila i
thought it was handled in a really
self-aware way
that felt natural for the show we know
the audience knows this yeah so how can
we like talk about this in a way where
we don't have to sacrifice it from the
show but be aware that like
the audience knows yeah the show's been
doing a great job with that especially
with the scene with klaus last
last episode kind of calling everybody
out of their [ __ ] yeah they know
what the audience is thinking which is
great
guys i love this show please please
subscribe and click that bell to get
notified whenever i got a new youtube
video up check out a full-length
reaction on patreon all those other
shows and
let's do a patron of the day shout out
andrew hayes how's it going talking with
you lately and you've been telling me
how you haven't been able to be active
on your channel because you haven't been
watching as many movies because there's
no movies coming out i wanted to
encourage you bud there's so much on
streaming services right now that i know
you would absolutely love i love hearing
your opinion on things i think you have
a wonderful on-camera personality i feel
like this is a great opportunity for you
right now to
get a little bit creative and you know
do something a little bit challenging
and exciting for yourself
on your youtube channel but if you don't
want to do that and instead just touch
yourself all day like you have been
then fine that's your call man has
nothing to do with
my life i'm just saying you have a lot
of potential
don't waste it put it on youtube review
what you're touching yourself to
two birds one stone and there you go
that's great or two nuts one stone
that's for you that's wholesome i'm just
kidding andrew i love you buddy
do whatever the [ __ ] you wanna do
[Music]